le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais la jeunesse réunionnaise
c'est l'avenir de la Réunion l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle des jeunes
réunionnés est donc un enjeu majeur les
jeunes doivent renforcer leur autonomie
et acquérir les compétences nécessaire
pour accéder à un emploi ou à une
solution d'insertion pérenne et par fois
pour des jeunes en difficulté il est
essentiel de leur redonner confiance en
eux et en leur capacités alors comment
déclencher l'envie de réussir chez les
jeunes comment les aider à faire les
bons choix pour leur avenir on en parle
maintenant dans lien
social les jeunes manquent de confiance
en eux et d'accompagnement humain leur
montrer l'exemple leur apprendre à côté
d'un savoirfaire savoir-être avec une
estime de soi sont devenus essentiels
pour leur épanouissement ils sont
l'avenir de la Réunion c'est sur ce
raisonnement que le Conseil général
propose aux jeunes d'être soutenus et
accompagnés par un par un dans le cadre
du Plan ambition jeunesse pour soutenir
cette action destinée et attirer à la
fois les jeunes et les futurs parins le
Conseil général a fait le choix de lui
donner un parrain d'envergure un exemple
pour les jeunes une des personnalités
préférées des Français tant pour ses
compétences sportives que pour sa
personnalité et son charisme Yannick
Noah les jeunes un peu en fait c'est
l'avenir et donc c'est un petit peu à
nous les anciens de de leur montrer la
voix de les motiver surtout et motiver
par des conseils forcément mais aussi
par une présence euh j'ai pour objectif
de passer plus de temps à la Réunion on
va venir notamment faire nos répétitions
pour la prochaine une tournée notre
prochaine tournée en métropole on va
répéter à la Réunion en fait à chaque
fois que j'ai la possibilité jeevens à
la Réunion et là ben voilà c'est c'est
une belle opportunité pour moi je vais
pouvoir être sur place et c'est c'est
une belle occasion pour moi je suis très
content et même très touché comm est
sollicité justement pour ce projet je
pense c'est un très bon projet et je
suis très content et fier d'être d'être
le parrain voilà essaie de contacter
rentrer en contact avec les jeunes leur
parler discuter de nos différentes
expériences ce qui important c'est de
les les écouter individuellement pouvoir
savoir qui ils sont savoir qu'il sachent
qui je suis qu'on ait l'occasion de se
rencontrer plusieurs fois parce que il
s'agit pas tout d'un coup de venir une
fois discuter puis partir salut bonne
chance à bientôt je pense queil faut
qu'il ait un suivi je je crois vraiment
à cette à ce travail de proximité très
très souvent les enfants en difficulté
ou des jeunes en difficulté ou des
jeunes qui sont en demande pas forcément
en difficulté mais en demande ont besoin
d'un suivi ils ont besoin parfois d'être
épaulés
encouragés mais cet encouragement il
doit être suivi c'est quelque chose qui
doit être à long terme je crois pas au
au coup voilà faire un coup comme ça ça
donne un peu d'énergie et puis ça
retombe très vite comme un souffler je
crois qu'il y a il faut qu'il s'installe
une vraie relation et puis après les
énergies Ben se se partagent et
s'additionne et voilà à la fin je me
sentirai quelque part responsable et
puis ils seront aussi responsablebl
parce que leurs parins attendre à deux
bah qu'ils assurent quoi voilà c'est je
peux répondre à cette question que d'une
manière assez générale mais à la fin je
sais pour avoir été entraîneur de
joueurs et de joueuses que il y a pas de
formule magique ce qui compte c'est
l'écoute s'écouter que je les écoute qui
m'écoute qu'on se fasse confiance et
ensuite qu'on aille ensemble et qu'on
décide une direction et qu'on y aille à
fond quoi l'action du parrain y compris
celle de Yannick Noah est bénévole
chaque parrain doit jouer un rôle rôle
de soutien de conseil de facilitateur
voire de modèles dans l'atteinte des
objectifs visés par le jeune il doit
construire une relation directe et de
confiance avec le jeune se rendre
disponible durant les différentes phases
du parcours et s'engager à être présent
lors des différents entretiens
d'évaluation programmés par le référent
la valeur ajoutée de l'action du parrain
et de consacrer aux jeunes le temps que
le professionnel du conseil général ne
peut lui accorder dans ce cadre il
définit librement avec le jeune les
modalités d'organisation de leurs
relations la jeunesse réunionnaise est
un atout pour la Réunion mais elle est
aussi devenue un public vulnérable
pourquoi parce que les dispositifs
existent mais les jeunes ne sont pas
toujours informés et il n'y a pas de
cohérence vis-àis de ces dispositifs
trop répandu trop de portes à ouvrir et
ce parénage âge de 4000 jeunes est une
belle opération où ces jeunes parénés
auront un interlocuteur un référent qui
pourront qui pourra les accompagner et
en même temps un parrain un peu comme le
grand frère ou papa maman qui pendant
une année va porter ses jeunes en leur
disant vous pouvez nous appeler et et
nous pouvons être le grand frère qui
vous manque pour vous aider vous
orienter accompagner ces jeunes et
j'invite donc tous ceux qui veulent à la
Réunion être des parins à rejoindre le
conseil général et à nous appeler la
solidarité est une des plus belles
valeurs de la Réunion grâce au
parrainage nous transmettons cette
valeur et construisons avec les jeunes
la réunion de demain pour participer au
programme et devenir Parin
renseignez-vous sur le site du Conseil
Général ou directement par téléphone au
0262 94 29 29 nous comptons sur
vous le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais